oh
it's right around time to say goodbye to
the year it's overall been a great anime
season and it's apt to consider what
lies ahead so with the winter season
starting us as we approach the year 2023
what does it have in store for everyone
I've come to compile what I think are
the top 10 most anticipated new anime
coming out in January so it's going to
be a very happy New Year for all us
anime fans let's start with Revenger
quite the edgy title we've got there huh
I think it's pretty cool and appropriate
about a gritty story of an assassin and
the Survivor teaming up together going
on their quest for well you got it
Revenge when Master assassin yusui cross
paths with gurima the two set off to
uncover the mystery behind the series of
murders aimed at the members of the
Satsuma Samurai Clan it does seem that
there's more to the series of
assassinations than a mere conflict of
resources digging deeper into the truth
draws the abyss closer to them however
and one has to wonder if they'll come
out of this conspiracy alive it's got
some pretty cool visuals from what I can
see and given that it's anime original I
am expecting a lot of surprises it looks
great and while the story may not seem
unique who knows what twist these guys
from agiado have got for us after all
these are the guys that gave us kimono
jihen and with the overall Vibes feeling
quite alike I'm expecting something
pretty awesome in terms of execution
number nine is rom-com the icy guy and
his cool female colleague
[Music]
the title sounds like something from a
typical rom-com you guys know the drill
the tropes and all of that but what if I
tell you that this title is actually
more literal than what you'd expect
himero here is caught in a dilemma how
could you not when you're literally a
supernatural being whose emotions can
trigger snowstorms yeah he's warm and
likes a lot of things but thanks to this
bothersome power he can't get close to
anything that he loves it's made much
worse though when he's got feelings for
fuyutsuki fuyutsuki doesn't help with
how much she AIDs that helpless
protagonist triggering his icy powers
even more but that's not going to stop
him or snow storms blizzards or icy
winds won't be able to deny him the
chance to express his love for his
colleague he'll do whatever it takes to
capture her heart now this is a premise
that I can get behind I haven't touched
the source material admittedly but it's
got a premise That's Unique so I can't
help but get curious all I know is that
we're in for a world of awkward moments
and hours of laughter with this one
rom-com fans should definitely check
this one out
before we move on to the next entry take
some time to thank today's sponsors for
your Tranquility for your Tranquility is
an upcoming game that combines mystery
and adventure in a package like we've
never seen before for your Tranquility
after all deals with the subject of
autopsies it's a game where you take the
role of a forensic doctor and use your
big brains to determine the truth behind
the cases that you get assigned things
aren't what they seem at first and just
as easy as it is to guess and determine
the answer to the case it's just as easy
to mistake a blood stain for spilled
Source making your assumptions of a
violent fight go completely off the
rails for your Tranquility offers
various endings too and if you're good
enough to discover the truth you'll get
to see the ending to a very engaging
story that's full of twists and turns
also while the subject of autopsies may
not be for everyone the team has done
their best to just tone things down
going as far as telling the story in a
world without humans and in a visual
novel style so if you're up for some
mystery games maybe a way of testing
your metal then why not try it for your
Tranquility out it's available on Steam
this December and you can go on and add
the game to your wish list now
spy room is up next in the number 8 spot
war is such a horrible thing brutal and
barbaric too that's why after another
one of the many gruesome Wars in history
the world's government's had enough and
switched to it just as effective yet
more finesse way of conducting conflict
spy wars fought in the shadows the
upstart Lydia feels very confident in
her written skills and she seems poised
to be one of the promising young spies
there is one problem though her
practical skills are terrible there's
just no way that someone like her is
graduating from the Spy institution or
does she thankfully Fate has an
interesting way of working things out
and she finds herself with the
opportunity of a lifetime to go on an
impossible mission with the domoshibi
team however Lily's promising run with
this new Squad might just come to a
screeching halt when she realizes the
true purpose of the team and what
impossible mission is it's a show that's
full of twists that will keep you
guessing and thinking all while growing
attached to this ragtag squad of girls
now I'm not going to spoil much more of
what I've read but let me just tell you
that is very much like assassination
classroom so if you're a fan of that
show you might want to check this one
out too
[Music]
at number seven we have the original
anime giant beasts of ours
[Music]
if what you're craving is the good old
medievalish jrpg feel then giant beasts
of ours may just be your jam giant Beast
of ours takes place in a world divided
by conflict while great beasts created
the world humans took control of it even
calling upon the gods to Aid them in
their Conquest now as the conflict rages
on beasts and humans hunt each other
relentlessly and peace is nowhere in
sight enter Beast hunted Giro after
saving the girl Kumi the two decide to
travel together the two seek to unravel
the world's secrets and the true role of
humanity in a mysterious experiment with
how things came to be Venture into the
world of swords and Magic once again
with this promising new anime coming
your way this winter season with the guy
behind bangers like aquadama drive and
school live in the team I'm pretty sure
this is going to be a good one it is an
original anime though so we
unfortunately don't have any first-hand
info of how the story is going to go
Gotta watch it this season to find out
[Music]
we return to rom-com land for our sixth
entry Kubo won't let me be invisible
[Music]
people all have their various Desires in
high school right sure there are those
brooding guys who prefer to be left
alone but there are those who want to
make an impact too you know make a
strong impression and enjoy their image
of a fulfilling youth Jean dashiraishi
Falls squarely into the latter but he's
got a problem you see he's got so little
presence that no one seems to notice him
at all there is hope though however as
there's exactly one person who notices
him Nagisa Kubo on the flip side Nagisa
is the type of girl who would tease him
on a daily basis putting him in all
sorts of compromising situations while
doing it as well perhaps this is the
bright and eventful youth that shiraishi
always wanted the premise makes it seem
like something inspired by takagi's son
and after having a great time with the
show this is something I could
definitely give a passing look at it
looks to be another one of those sweet
and wholesome high school rom-coms that
you can enjoy when needing your weekly
dose
card game anime are still the rage so
here we go now with high card but just
take a chance
[Music]
underground societies and mafia families
bloody shout outs special cards that
bestow superhuman abilities to their
wielders now that sounds like the recipe
for an edgy card game anime with a
slightly older target audience in mind
I'm not gonna lie okay this takes card
game anime to a whole new level high
card aims to capture the thrill of card
games like the high stakes the
unpredictable nature of them and tries
to integrate it with a setting that will
evoke shows like death parade if you get
what I mean that or a setting
reminiscent of 91 days or similar shows
filled with the violent fights fueled by
clashing desires meanings of justice and
a thirst for Revenge whether the
ambitious project works or not is still
up in the air but I definitely am in the
market for a slightly different approach
to card game anime
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fans experience a lot for such a male
dominated fandom I mean my Discord
server starts back it up at least
there's usually one or two girls who
become part of the group sharing some
fun times with us and eventually being
one of the Bros so to speak I mean it is
really great honestly but what if it
comes to a point when the girl wants to
start confessing her feelings that's a
realistic setup that this show aims to
address all in a fun manner of course
completely different from the series
where I approach the Dilemma but those
difficulties won't ever be enough to
deter Domo from confessing to her best
buddy Jean after all she is a girl in
love and there are far too few forces
strong enough to hold back a determined
girl's advances what happens is a whole
slew of comedic hijinks as Donald tries
to desperately get her message across
unfortunately though with how
thick-headed Jean is it's even harder
than you think it would seem adapted
from a manga that spanned over 900
chapters tomochan is a girl is a title
that will leave you in stitches these
characters are just so fun to root for
and I'm sure you'll have a great time
following their Misadventures in anime
form
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you've heard the saying that no good
deed goes unrewarded or something to
that effect well sure things can't be
said when we look at our money who knew
that lending a girl like mahiru your
umbrella would get you one of the
sweetest Angels possible a girl who
takes it upon herself to help you
recover from sickness and everything
there is just one problem our
protagonist here isn't exactly the
neatest person around and mahiru quickly
finds his apartment to be completely
unsightly but there's no reason to
despair for mahiru is here to set this
hopeless guy straight and put him on the
right path when a random good dude bags
you a superintendent who could seemingly
do everything things can only get better
right but how long will this Arrangement
last when our protagonists managed to
set his own life straight with help from
this blessing of a cute girl I guess
we'll have to watch this cute
entertaining series set to hit our
screens this winter season
Baka
let's start the march to the end with a
blast from the past try gun stampede
lost in the shuffle of a lot of the
Vintage Classics in this gem I've always
felt that Trigun as a series got the
short end of the stick not that it's
anything underappreciated or anything
like that but it's less popular and less
mentioned compared to a lot of its
contemporaries that people now look back
on fondly but it's a show that has a
really cool world really flashy action
and some unique humor all which solidify
its spot as yet another classic from the
Childhood Days of people as old as I am
thankfully anime fans of the modern era
will finally get to experience what
Trigun is all about with this brand new
anime looking to Breathe new life into
the franchise Trigun Stampede is coming
and it looks like it's here to retell
the story of what we've grown to love a
prequel and a reboot it serves as a way
to connect the bridge between
generations of anime fans reintroducing
the story of Vash the Stampede and his
brother knives both all-time fans and
new fans are welcome to jump into the
world of Trigun where gripping action
awaits
finally we have near automata wrapping
up the list
now in contrast to Trigun fans Neo fans
don't have to wait too long for an anime
adaptation of this smash hit series
video game adaptations have been picking
up slack recently and I fully expect
this near anime to make a huge impact
moving forward near as a Series has
always been an object of intrigue it's
got a lot of elements you see that made
it click as a video game I'm sure that a
lot of it would translate beautifully in
anime form the trailers already got
people buzzing and feeling the
excitement I can't wait until the actual
episode to see if all the hype is
Justified with the news that the story
has been changed for the anime
adaptation I am personally more Curious
I do hope that some key elements from
the game will be kept as the game's
story is nothing short of amazing still
there's nothing bad with seeing the
Sci-Fi sensation finally hit the anime
World smashingly beautiful visuals sound
Direction it's on point and a world of
possibilities I can't wait to see where
near automatcher brings to us in its big
anime debut
that wraps up the list hope you were
able to find something to watch this
season as always if you had a great time
hit that like button up there and add a
subscription or two and don't forget to
check out for your Tranquility it does
seem to be an interesting game that will
push your mental muscles to their limits
so be sure to check it out using the
link in the description thanks for your
time and thanks for watching hoping to
see you again when I start rolling out
more of the year in its review list that
we'll be having in the days and weeks to
come